Rudy and I came across minimalism sort
of by accident we had heard about Dave
Ramsey and the fire movement and we
embarked on the arduous task of becoming
debt free
because of this we found ourselves
selling many of our possessions one to
put towards our debt but also because we
just wanted to have less things to
manage and maintain and I personally
wanted to free myself from my horrible
shopping addiction for about a year or
so I actually had no idea that the
things that I was applying in my life
was called minimalism and that
decluttering was even a thing I just
knew that I was simplifying my life but
since then I've definitely noticed many
benefits so today I'm going to share
with you the 10 benefits that I've
experienced by adopting minimalism into
my life and definitely not because it's
the most important one but really just
because this is what began my personal
Journey with minimalism is that it saves
you money at the time that I was
adopting these minimalist principles I
found myself constantly shopping all the
time because I had gone from a cashier
salary at that time was 7.50 to a
registered nurse making 21 or 22 I can't
remember dollars an hour I tripled my
salary and you better believe that I had
lifestyle creep I was constantly
shopping for new clothes and decor items
because I had just gotten married and I
had a house to decorate I've talked
about my horrible shopping habits in
another video I can link that in case
you're interested but minimalism is
definitely what helped me combat my
shopping addiction one because it helped
really make me purchase things with
intention and actually thinking about
the long term and also it just freed me
from that constant desire that I need to
have more and that there's something
that I'm missing that I'm lacking it
really helped promote kind of a sense of
enough and feeling of gratitude that I
don't need a lot of other things in
order to be happier to fill me so it
helped with kind of just the mindset of
not wanting so many things but also with
the things that I do want I'm a lot more
intentional about them now when I make a
purchase I'm really thinking about long
term is this something that I'm going to
use for a while is this good quality and
will it save me money in the long run
even if it means that I spend a little
bit more in the beginning so for example
I purchased a lot of reusable items I've
talked about like my reusable sponges or
reusable oil spray bottle for example
those things definitely cost more than
if I were to buy just the Disposable
packs but when I consider the long term
I really end up saving a whole lot more
money
so buying less things buying better
quality and really looking towards
long-term purchases has saved me major
cash and not to mention selling a lot of
those things that we were not using made
us major money the second way in which
minimalism has improved my life is that
it has freed up more time and this
really became apparent to me when I
began to think of my money as time
because if you think about it when you
go to a store to purchase an item you're
handing that clerk over money money that
you spent hours maybe maybe even weeks
or months in order to obtain having less
things to maintain means that you have
to spend less time cleaning less time
picking things up and maintaining them
and taking care of them so it frees up
more time to be able to do the things
that you love
a major time saving declutter that we
experienced is that we don't have a
television and actually except for this
YouTube channel we don't have any social
media not having these things means that
we have more time to be able to spend
together as a family and to be with our
friends and loved ones and to return to
Old hobbies that we had completely
forgotten about it's also helped me to
increase productivity and focus I
remember hearing a while back ago that
all of the things that you have
decorating your home all of the word
signs and labels all of those things are
trying to grab your brain's attention
even if you see a pen on the floor that
you're like oh I'm gonna pick it up I'm
gonna pick it up I'm gonna pick it up
your brain is constantly thinking about
that it's constantly trying to obtain
your attention having less stuff around
my home just makes it more tranquil it
makes it less things that I have to
constantly be thinking about fixing
arranging or cleaning making it easier
for me to focus on the thing that I
really want to focus on
another awesome benefit is that it
focuses more on experiences rather than
things so rather than constantly
focusing on obtaining more things or
receiving gifts for example it focuses
on doing things together that builds
relationship bonds which just in general
can increase your life satisfaction
another cool benefit is that when you
know everything that you have in your
home and you just have less things
everything has a home so things rarely
get lost I remember when my husband and
I first got married we were so guilty of
constantly asking each other hey have
you seen this thing
and often going to the store to purchase
something that we thought we no longer
had because we just didn't know where we
put things we would just stash it in the
closet and forget about it so if you
constantly lose things this can be a
game changer for you the next benefit
that I experienced is truly amazing and
it's that it increased a sense of
gratitude I mentioned that I had a
horrible shopping addiction and back
when I had a huge closet with lots of
different colored purses and high heels
that I never wore but couldn't find
myself letting go of because they were
beautiful even though I very well knew I
would never wear
I was buying all of these things because
I felt empty Within Myself I couldn't
find worth Within Myself and I wanted to
apply it extrinsically I needed
something to fill my void but when I let
go of that I was then opening myself up
to gratitude because then I could
appreciate the small things that I do
have without feeling like I need to
constantly have more on a lighter note
it has also freed up more time for
hobbies and creativity I remember when I
read the artist's Way by Julia Cameron
was when I realized that creativity is
important for us it's something that
children just naturally have but because
of the busyness of life and constantly
focusing on the next thing that we have
to do we often forget about it
I remember that when we first got rid of
the television and social media it felt
like what hobbies do I have and what do
I even like to do because I had just
constantly gotten into the zone of being
a consumer rather than thinking of what
I could create and when I started to
create art and do things just for fun
just because I wanted to it was
definitely a lot happier because of it I
personally believe that if we are made
in the image and likeness of a creator
then we are meant to be creative
and by getting rid of excess and noise
in my life I've opened myself up for
creativity the next benefit is that it
can help improve your health so when
you're constantly stressed your body
releases cortisol and cortisol is
related to inflammation inflammation is
related to pretty much every disease out
there so by reducing our stress reducing
the worries that we have throughout the
day we can reduce disease
not only that but if you have more time
now you have a lot more energy and that
you can put towards exercising cooking
better meals sleeping more and just
feeling better overall so that you can
give your best to everyone around you
and yourself
this next one is super simple but I love
it and that it's easier to tidy up your
home so when you get that random phone
call from your friend that says hey I'm
gonna drop something off be there in 15
minutes you don't find yourself with the
deer and headlights look because now you
have to figure out where to stuff
everything so that you can tidy up
before they get there having less things
means that you can do that in 15 minutes
and it's no biggie no sweat unless of
course you're me and your kids just have
a fort in the living room then it's just
gonna be what it is and lastly but
definitely not least improved
relationships I've previously mentioned
how getting rid of our television
dramatically improved our marriage there
are so many ways in which minimalism has
helped me have better relationships from
helping me ease insecurities by removing
that sense that I constantly need more
in that shopping addiction for example
to having better boundaries and
declaring my schedule where I don't do
things out of guilt or because I feel
like I'm gonna let somebody down if I
don't do something to having more time
to spend with the people that I love
there are so many other benefits that I
could mention in relationship to
minimalism and I think that's because it
is unique to you and your lifestyle so
hopefully by sharing with you these 10
benefits that I have experienced it can
be a motivation to you but be sure to
share your experience as well what has
your experience been with minimalism let
me know in the comments below if you
made it this far I am sorry for my
measly voice I am sick today but I still
wanted to get a video to you I thank you
so much for watching I thank you for
your support and if there's any videos
that you would like to see in the future
let me know in the comments or send me
an email I thank you so much for
watching and I will see you in the next
one bye for now